have you found any connection between
near-death experiences and the
phenomenon
or any other part of your studies and
near-death experiences i at some point
in the summer plan on taking a deep dive
into them but
starting with dean raiden if you've
heard of him but i haven't done so yet
so i'm curious yes i know dean um
so yes i have actually um what's really
interesting right now is that i'm doing
some research into japanese ufos
and um what i think is really
interesting is that they're different
i would call them like different ufos
there's our you know the u.s military's
ufo right which is you know these things
that like lou elizondo talks about and
that kind of thing well that looks a
little bit different than the ufos that
the japanese talk about okay
and then you know so so near-death
experiences what i found is this is that
strangely
people who've had near-death experiences
seem to have a lot of these post ufo
effects
that people who see ufos have
which is i don't know if you and again i
hate to do this but i'm going to uh the
movie arrival i don't like to cite a
movie as as a as a framework for like
you know talking about something but in
this movie arrival um one of the gifts
that the aliens give to humans is the
the knowledge of time like you know that
time is actually you know they had four
knowledge and you know time is not
linear so you can know things and so a
lot of people who have near-death
experiences and who have had
experiences of a ufo all of a sudden
seem to know things that are going to
happen
um some not all of them but a lot of
them and uh so this is something that i
found i also found that a lot of people
who've had ufo experiences
seem to associate those ufo experiences
with um where people died so i know an
experienced servant who's a very
well-known experiencer
and he said that he saw a ufo where his
wife had died of a car accident years
earlier
now in japan
these orbs that you know here in the
united states we call them ufos but they
see them in japan
they're they're identified as souls like
souls that of debt deceased people like
during the tsunami of 2011 there were so
many of these and people saw them and
they said these are the souls right of
the people who died during the tsunami
and so i i think that's really
interesting so yeah there's some
correlations there